[MUSIC PLAYING]
BILL NYE: No, it's all good.
[EXPLOSION NOISE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're delighted
to welcome Salman Rushdie
to discuss his 12th novel.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is Dikembe
Mutombo, and he was born in--
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: Dikembe Mutombo
Mpolondo Mukamba [INAUDIBLE]
Jean-Jacques Wamutombo.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
DIKEMBE MUTOMBO: I thought
you were going to introduce me
with my man names.
MARIE KONDO: [SPEAKING JAPANESE]
BRANDON SANDERSON: I am
reading a flashback sequence
for a character
named Dalinar, which
means that if you haven't read
the other "Stormlight" books,
it's not a spoiler
because it takes place
30 years before the
first book begins.
BILL MURRAY: Is this beer?
MALE SPEAKER: That is beer.
BILL MURRAY: I'm not
really a beer guy.
I'm more of a hard liquor guy.
Are you a beer girl, right here?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JOHN CLEESE: Because that's
what journalists write about.
And then I say at the
end, what did you think?
They say, oh, they
thought it was hilarious.
I say, well, could you say so?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
MALE SPEAKER: I thought
it was hilarious.
JOHN CLEESE: [LAUGHS]
Thank you [INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUNDAR PICHAI: Shah
Rukh and I were
walking when a bunch
of Googlers just
did a flash dance and Shah Rukh
joined in the back as well.
AUDIENCE: [CHEERS]
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Absolute pleasure
to welcome Guillermo del
Toro, Jessica Chastain, Tom
Hiddleston, and Mia Wasikowska!
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUDS]
JOHN BOYEGA: I went on YouTube--
I should have said Google,
but nah, it was YouTube.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, we own that.
JOHN BOYEGA: Oh, you do?
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
JOHN BOYEGA: Boom.
COLIN CLOUD: You've
got the seven.
You've got the eight.
You've got the nine.
You've got the 10.
You've got the jack.
You've got the queen.
You've got the king, and
you've got the joker.
You were wondering whether
or not I was going to say it.
Is that right?
Yes!
MALE SPEAKER: And
how much of you
is in Dwight, and how
much of Dwight is in you?
RAINN WILSON: That's
what she said.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHS]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICHARD ENGEL: It takes
courage to be good.
It takes courage to be kind.
It's easy to be mean.
[PIANO PLAYING]
MALE SINGER: I don't do
sadness, not even a little bit.
Just don't need it in my life.
EDUARDO MIRANDA RODRIGUEZ:
You got to do it.
DARRYL "DMC"
MCDANIELS [RAPPING]:
This speech is my recital.
I think it's very vital to rock
a rhyme that's right on time.
"It's Tricky" is the title.
Let's sing it.
It's tricky to rock
a rhyme, to rock
a rhyme that's right on time.
It's tricky!
It's tricky, tricky,
tricky, tricky!
It's tricky to
rock a rhyme, rock
a rhyme that's right on time.
It's tricky!